[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here so
this is the ipad pro this is the m1 ipad
at the top of the food chain best ipad
there is and i've been using this thing
a lot for the last month or so
and i really like it and like a lot of
other ipad users it's just really
enjoyable to use this ipad
but i still wanted more from it because
as you probably remember from this
review this thing is way more powerful
than any software that's taken advantage
of it like the m1 chip in here
benchmarks higher than the 16-inch
macbook pro
there's 16 gigs of ram in this tablet
it's crazy
and so it felt like it's finally time
for some big updates
to ipad os
and i wasn't the only one who said this
on camera
the ipad os 15 update that's coming up
has got to be a pretty significant
change
to what we have now in ipad os 14.5 like
it's got to be right maybe
hopefully this is the year that we see
apple put
like real
real apps in this thing like final cut
and this is honestly super exciting
because that's going to make this thing
so incredibly powerful that it really is
setting this ipad up to be able to do
some really amazing things maybe even
run final cut pro that is me crossing my
fingers now we're currently filming this
video two days before wwdc 2021 where
apple is expected to announce some new
features for the ipad os i think
i just i hope
that the extra ram is indicative of
something brewing for wwdc
well
uh you know what else was also once said
on video
expectations
are the thief of joy meaning we got our
hopes up pretty high for all these big
changes we wanted to see in the software
but there was almost no way that
whatever they announced could live up to
what we wanted to see
and so ipad os 15 it's it's nice it's a
nice update with some some tweaks and ui
things refreshes that makes sense on the
ipad
but it didn't
change the way i use the ipad and it
didn't really even get it much closer at
all to actually replacing a computer
the way i kind of wanted it to
and i feel like that's kind of just
where the ipad is
destined to live for their furso future
but let's not let the expectations be
the thief of joy because i've been using
this beta ipad os 15 for a little bit
like i said there's been a developer
beta now there's a public beta it's
really good there's a lot of good stuff
i'm going to show you the stuff that's
made the most difference to me that i
like the most about the ipad and then i
have some thoughts on ipads as a whole
so the biggest change we've all seen by
now is you can finally finally put
widgets anywhere on the ipad's home
screen you know like you could with
android tablets for the last decade it
really shouldn't feel like that big of
an upgrade but it does for the ipads
since they were confined over to the
slide over area before where you can
still put them by the way but now you
just have all this huge canvas to lay
them out and it's so much better plus
there's also a new bigger widget size so
you can really use some massive widgets
you can have a whole home screen that's
just 100 widgets if you want to but then
the other home screen upgrade that the
ipad gets is the app library now too
which just shows all of your apps in one
place so of course you can now hide apps
from your home screen that you don't
want and it actually feels really
natural that it just pops up after your
last home screen so this is a long time
coming i really like this new
essentially app drawer for the ipad the
big thing that always comes up the most
with the ipad though
is
multitasking
or at least having more than one thing
open on the screen at once it's a huge
canvas but you might not necessarily be
multitasking sometimes you just need two
windows to do one task like you're
taking notes on something or copying and
pasting between apps
things like that and so yeah it's not
necessarily
multitasking but it is
going to need window management so ipads
running ipad os 15 technically handle
multiple windows exactly the same as
before but the upgrade here is it's more
visible and it's way easier to remember
so they surfaced it by just constantly
showing you these three dots up here
anytime you open an app there's a three
dots up top and when you tap the three
dots it shows you three simple options
full screen with one app split screen
or slide over so if you split screen you
can pick another app to go split screen
with and right away your half and half
so you can just copy and paste or go
back and forth multitask or whatever you
want to call it the way you could before
and if you pick slide over all the same
slide over app support still exists as
well i don't use slide over as much as
i've seen some other people but the
functionality and the support is still
the same there's a bunch of small tall
vertical apps in their own carousel
in multitasking view though you can also
now drag one window right on top of
another to create a split screen with
them and then just dive straight into
that which is pretty cool and if you
ever have two apps open and you just
want to replace one of them with
something different you just swipe down
from the top of that one and you can
replace it and get your substitute in
now you're not crazy a lot of this stuff
is the same as before it's the same
function as before but it's just
presented more obviously now and i like
that i really like the dots actually
that's just it's made everything easier
to remember now there are also apps like
safari where you can have multiple
instances of the same app open and so
when you open safari at the bottom on
the new shelf it shows all of the
windows you've got open each with their
own tabs you know got their own things
happening and so that to me was the part
that felt the most like a
computer like i all the time i have
multiple safari windows open next to
each other taking notes especially when
i'm writing
but on the ipad if you want to split
screen any one of these safari apps you
can so you can tap the safari icon and
now it's like oh did you want to use
this one safari window here or a split
screen of this different safari window
with
photos next to it or whatever other app
you have going on next to it no problem
now the other biggest ui change to ipad
os 15 is definitely the notes app
now you might be like me and
never really use the notes app very much
because there's other better to-do list
apps there's other better notes apps
but
notes on this new ipad software is so
good that it is honestly tempting for me
to use it over some other stuff like
like pocket that i use all the time to
just jot stuff down or just remember
something i need to come back to later
this is really good so there's a new
quick notes feature where you drag up
from the corner with your finger or the
pencil and straight away you can start
writing something down or typing a quick
note and then that gets added to a
dedicated quick notes section of apple
notes but it's a bit deeper than that
because you can drag whatever you're
doing right into that quick note so sam
in twitter for example and i want to
remember this tweet i can literally just
drag this tweet right into a note and
save it there for later write something
down about it whatever you want to do
you can drag a photo from your gallery
into a note it'll just add that photo to
the note or if i'm on a website you can
swipe up a quick note and immediately
add the link you're at and with the
apple pencil you can quickly highlight
something on that page so later in quick
notes when you click on that link it
returns you to the page with that same
thing highlighted how cool is that how
cool is that so all of that plus the
really good handwriting recognition and
obviously it's syncing between this and
the mac and the iphone and all the stuff
that has the notes app it's really
tempting
i'm gonna keep using pocket i think for
all this same stuff just because it also
syncs to my android phone and i'd i'll
be damned if i have one more plug-in
into the ecosystem but
yeah the notes app now is really good
but then there's some there's some other
smaller stuff uh safari for the ipad
gets web extensions like the desktop
version so if you go into safari
settings and scroll down to extensions
you can just go load up the section of
the store specifically for safari
extensions i'm sure many more will be
added here too when it's out of beta
probably including a dedicated save to
pocket button and there's also all the
other stuff that's coming to ios 15 on
the iphone too stuff like share play and
facetime
live text on photos in the gallery apple
maps updates etc so if you want to look
at all that stuff i'll link my video
right below the like button love focus
modes of course spoiler alert that's my
favorite number one feature but there's
a bunch of good stuff in ios 15. and
they're also going to be adding that
universal control feature that was a
super cool demo to control your ipad
with a mouse seamlessly from a mac
running mac os monterey oh and also i
want to show you guys this better
because i didn't i failed you guys in
the last video i thought notification
summary wasn't in the last beta but it
is you just have to turn it on so to
enable it you go into settings and
notifications and then scheduled summary
and then from here when you turn it on
you can literally choose which apps you
want to be looped into notification
summaries so maybe instead of a random
google news notification in the middle
of the day buzzing you you can have that
and some others literally just collect
and then show up in a summary at the end
of the day nice but aside from that ipad
os is
still just how you remember it which is
really fun to use a lot of times just
slightly frustratingly limited sometimes
also this there's still no weather app
by the way so there's this huge weather
widget but when you click on it it just
opens safari and goes to weather.com
you bought dark sky just make a weather
app also there's still no calculator app
officially on the ipad you can have a
little widget from the quick settings or
the control panel but
yeah there's no uh there's no full
screen weather app or calculator app in
the ipad but generally this is the
update that we're all talking about and
waiting for
and for those of us who were teetering
on being able to use our ipad pro full
time and get rid of any laptop
i don't think ipad os 15 is the thing
that pushes us over the edge it doesn't
really change that i keep doing this
this ipad only challenge for myself even
though i've done it on video before
where i just won't use my laptop for a
while and i'll just try to use the ipad
for everything and this update
didn't really lengthen the amount of
time it took before i got frustrated and
had to bring my laptop again but it did
make the time i was using the ipad
that much better so i think the thing to
keep in mind here just the background to
all of this is the ipad's great
um it comes from a company that also
makes laptops
right so
even though they've got all this big
talk in this marketing campaign what is
a computer
all that fun stuff
at the end of the day
this company also makes computers so if
they're going to keep selling those
computers the ipad basically has to stay
firmly in between the iphone
and the mac
and it's
it's until they prove us wrong basically
that i feel like that's still going to
be true uh they didn't become a two
trillion dollar company by being bad at
business they're not going to
cannibalize their own products this is
this is just where the ipad lives the
one thing i will say that's on the other
side of this is i'm reviewing all this
new software on the perspective of
someone who really wants to use this
full time on a thousand dollar ipad pro
but this software will also be on
everyone else's ipads on all the 329
ipads
you know in people's homes in schools
all the ipad airs people who aren't
replacing their entire computer or maybe
they don't need all that much
functionality and they can do everything
they want already with a normal ipad
and all those ipads will just get better
for this so that's the ipad os 15 update
so there you have it more visible
multitasking is my big takeaway but also
just like
here's the ipad here's what it'll do
it's not really touching this or this
and i i enjoy using the ipad and that's
that's what it comes down to but let me
know what your thoughts are in the
comments section below we can talk about
it either way
talk to you guys in the next one thanks
for watching
peace
[Music]